welcome to this new video by assembly
oil before we begin with top 5 digital
marketing certifications for 2024 let me
take you through a quick walk through
the history of digital marketing with
the birth of personal computers the
concept of digital marketing began to
take shape early marketers started
sharing emails to reach out to their
customers around 1994 the first ever
digital Banner went live on the website
hotwire.com the best part about this
Banner was the banner was clickable ad
in late 1990 with the birth of search
engines marketers began to optimize
their websites to get higher rankings
thereby getting relevant traffic which
impacted positively on sales and the
rest becomes history today in the
digital world around 98 of Internet
users are influenced by social media
platforms because of this strong user
base social media has turned to one of
the best Marketplace if compared to
traditional marketing digital marketing
has high Roi thus making it more cost
effective with the evolution and
marketing techniques a lot of jobs are
emerging in the Market opening doors for
skilled retail marketers on an average a
skill digital marketer earns up to 8
lakh rupees annually in India whereas in
U.S the salaries may go as high as 106
000 dollars per year so without any
further delay let's begin with top 5
digital marketing certifications
the number one on the list is post
graduate program in digital marketing by
Purdue this comprehensive course is one
stop solution for any aspiring digital
marketer it offers master classes from
Purdue University Howard publishing
cases Capstone projects 35 Plus digital
marketing tools and much more skills are
necessary for growth with this program
you will gain much needed skills for
digital marketing including keyword
research behavioral marketing SEO sem
social media marketing content marketing
and much more learn tools like chat GPT
Google Keyword Planner Google ads
YouTube analytics Google Trends RFS and
more gain expertise in building and
promoting your website using live
Interactive Learning an area of
experience is preferred for this cause
hurry up and enroll Now find the
complete course details from the link in
the description box at number two on the
list we have us Master digital marketing
course by IIM skills this master program
provides digital marketing training with
live online interactive classroom
covering all the essentials of digital
marketing gain in-depth understanding of
tools like Facebook ads Facebook
insights Google analytics Keyword
Planner semrush most Uber suggests and
more check the complete course details
from the official website of I am skills
moving ahead to number three we have
digital marketing Masters program this
online Masters program in digital
marketing offers expertise in SEO social
media PPC conversion optimization
analytics content mobile and email
marketing with 12 month access to the
course you will gain industry ready
skills work on real projects and attain
Facebook export sessions tools covered
in this programs are the most commonly
used tools in the digital marketing
industry naming a few YouTube analytics
Google Keyword Planner Google ads Bing
ads HootSuite Facebook LinkedIn Twitter
and there is a huge list to go with this
Masters program you get hands-on
experience with industry projects an
year of Prior experience is preferred
for this course get an amazing discount
by using the code ytb 15. join the
course from the link in the description
box
number four we have digital marketing
specialist by LinkedIn
it is taught by various experienced
professionals linkedin's online course
provides no pressure environment for
entry-level marketers wishing to build
the knowledge of digital marketing this
course has almost 20 hours of on-demand
videos broken down into 11 modules this
is an ideal course for people with
little or no experience with digital
marketing it provides comprehensive
overview of all the leading digital
channels including Google ads or PPC SEO
email and social media learner will also
get a basic introduction of Google
analytics content marketing Facebook and
Instagram and even learn the
fundamentals of graphic design using
Adobe products each video module
includes a quiz to test how much you
have learned and you will receive a
certificate upon the completion of all
modules the number five on the list is
digital marketing courses by digital
Vidya
digital Vidya is government of India
approved digital marketing platform that
provides various digital marketing
certifications in Google AdWords Google
analytics HubSpot and more the course
curriculum is designed with six core
modules making beginner to learn SEO
email marketing inbound marketing search
engine marketing search engine
optimization web analytics and much more
you can check the other courses you can
check the course details on the official
website of digital Vidya before we end
this video listen to what our Learners
say about our courses restarting your
career in a new country that too in a
new sector after a career break is
anything but hi my name is vriti and I
am a digital marketer by profession I
already had experience in sales and
public relations so I wanted to learn
digital marketing so I opted a
professional certification program in
digital digital marketing from Purdue
University offered by simply learn on
the basis of my past experience and on
my newly developed skill I landed my
first freelance project with a company
called the best part about this job is
it is remote I can stay at home I can be
with my kids and I can also focus on my
hobbies so here we wrap up top five
marketing certifications for 2024. if
you like this video subscribe to Simply
learn and stay tuned with latest updates
in the industry thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here